ROKESH JANKIE: So
let's get started.
Hadoop on Google Cloud Platform.
First of all, it's
extremely fast to set it up.
So nowadays, if you go to
probably the IT department
within your company, you'll
end up with the question,
oh, I need a Hadoop cluster
and it needs to be this big.
And next up, you get a
planning of five weeks or more
just to get started.
We need to
investigate, et cetera.
So what I'm going
to show you later on
is that it can be done in
like one and a half minutes
that you have a cluster ready
for operations with your data.
Another thing is, Hadoop is most
of the time seen as something
like a low-level
infrastructure thing that
is happening within the
whole cluster itself.
But actually, it's quite hard
being a good data engineer,
but what we want is that
you focus on your data
and not necessarily on
the infrastructure level.
That's something that
we can manage for you.
And most importantly,
you don't pay upfront
like thousands of dollars.
You just start.
And you'll see that
scaling up, scaling
down is something
that's very flexible
and actually built in
in the data product.
So if you look at the landscape
or the whole scope of where
we are today, you can go from
infrastructure to platform.
What does that mean?
On the one side,
you see on premise,
and that's actually how many
organizations are doing it.
They're trying it out.
And yeah, so at some moment,
you have an [INAUDIBLE]
for Hadoop like Cloudera
or another party which can
help you in this whole process.
There are some tools, like
bdutil which actually allows
you to do command
line activities
and create a cluster, but if
you want to have it like manage
but still have control
on everything what's
happening in there, Cloud
Data Park is your best friend.
And actually, the
last three categories
are provided by the
Google Cloud Platform.
So let's take a peek under the
hood of what Google Cloud Data
Park is.
First of all, you have
to think in layers.
The layer, which is actually
quite important, is--
first of all, think of who's
interacting with the system.
Then, you have the system.
And then, you have the
ecosystem of all the things
that are connected to
your Hadoop cluster.
I'd like to think,
also, in Hadoop cluster,
because it's nothing
else than that.
So if you're used to working
with your other cluster,
yes, you can.
If you want to do an
SSH to you other cluster
and run some Hadoop
jobs, yes, you can.
But you have to think in layers.
And the good part
is, you have options.
You can always go
like you wanted to go,
or like you did it so far.
We also provide some
APIs, which actually
have something nifty in there.
Because yes, I can start
a job, close my laptop,
go home, and see
the job finished.
So that's something that's
quite different with Hadoop jobs
that you probably have
in your cluster now.
Another thing is
that the Hadoop stack
that we have is of Apache beta.
That's actually like a
collection of Spark, Hadoop,
Hive, Pig, those tools that
are familiar in the Hadoop
stack itself.
On the other side,
of course, you
have the data processing part.
Then, you the analytics part.
And on the analytics
part, you see
that people plug in lots
of third-party tools
like Jupyter, Presto,
Zeppelin to that cluster.
And that's actually how we like
to see that you start using it.
So this is how Cloud
Dataproc is in the end.
So if you're planning
a PoC, a P-O-C,
there's one thing
that's happening,
I think-- and maybe the people
who just raised their hands
can confirm it-- that you start
off with a Hadoop cluster,
you say, OK, I have it.
Then you say, OK, now we
need something special--
Spark, PySpark, Hive, Pig,
everything on top of it.
Then, all of a sudden,
your data scientists
say, OK, I'd like
to access that data.
And then the plug in
Jupyter Notebook, et cetera.
So the good part
of the Hadoop stack
itself is that you can augment
that whole environment quite
well.
It's built for integration.
But on the other side, it
becomes a monolith in years.
And all of a sudden, people
say, OK, you know, it's running.
I'm not going to touch it.
And that's exactly why you have
to think not about lifting it
to a new environment,
but maybe you
have to rethink
what you're using.
And maybe you should
start to figure out,
OK, this is a
workaround, and this
is something I really need.
And that's something we're
going to see in a bit also.
So this is what you see,
quite often, happening,
which is actually
another good thing.
So if you look at the goals
that people can have, it's--
most of the time, it's
about cost savings--
how much do I save with it?
Our advice is, don't
go byte by byte,
but look at the whole
experience of it,
price, performance
in that context.
Scaling elasticity-- so
multi-cluster scale-out
is very easy.
If you want a burst for
just a couple of minutes,
it's actually quite easy.
If you don't have that capacity,
and you need it at that moment,
you can just say
it to the system.
And then, it will
give it to you back.
I'm saying say it.
Unfortunately, I don't have a
Hadoop demo with Google Home
device.
That would be really cool,
but that's for next time.
Then, for
development-- actually,
if you look at this
list, you probably
find one of the reasons
that you say, OK,
that's the reason why I
would like to move forward
to something new, because it's
becoming really expensive.
So another thing
that is something
that you should start
figuring out for yourself--
because each of the
environments are different,
they have a different need.
And that's actually
also how it starts.
Because it's not about,
I have one cluster,
and I'm going to do
everything with it.
Most of the time, that is
the end result of what's
happening now with
Hadoop in production.
So what you have to figure
out for yourself is,
what open-source
components are I
using, what is,
indeed, necessary,
and what is a workaround.
You might find some
things that you say, OK, I
shouldn't have done it.
But now I have a new option
to start doing it again,
but differently.
Another thing is the
system characteristics.
So we can natively
support HBase,
which is also very common
in a Hadoop cluster, HDFS,
of course, and many other
protocols that are quite known
in the Google Cloud.
But again, you
have to figure out,
yourself, what is necessary
for your environment.
Is it about SSDs?
Is it about, you
know, hard disks?
Is it about cold storage?
Is it data that I access
a lot, yes or no--
many characteristics that are
typical to your environment--
and also about the timeline,
your quota, your capacity.
So you know, it's very
hard to say, now, today--
I have encountered
one such situation
that people had to
bring in, seriously,
a sever rack,
configure it, and try
to do some calculations on
it, or some data science.
But in the end, that's
not where the value is.
It's not the hardware.
It's not the software also.
It's about what you get
out of your data that
is so common, so particular
to this specific client.
So that's why I would
say another thing that's
very important in this-- how do
I get my data into the system?
All this runs
around data, right?
And we're collecting
quite a lot nowadays.
So if you look at
the storage options,
you have a couple of them--
the Google Cloud Storage,
which is an object store--
so it has some other semantics--
HDFS and Dataproc
persistent disk--
so if you want to
have performance.
But if you want to go
higher in that context,
you can opt for SSDs.
Another thing is, if you
want to say, OK, fine,
I don't want to
manage my data at all,
then something like
Bigtable, Cloud Bigtable,
comes in, which, in fact,
is an HBase implementation.
So everything you
know from HBase
can be reused in
this context also.
And if you really don't want to
worry about the underlying part
and want to use, as mentioned
also in the keynote, Bigquery,
which is a no-ops data warehouse
solution that Google provides
in the cloud where you can
do petabyte-scale queries
in, like, minutes--
and it's becoming,
really, more important,
because we have some customers
that are generating petabytes
of data a day.
So then, Bigquery might
be another solution
to look at for storage.
Of course, if you look
at the timeline, it's--
some people use the
storage for archiving
or for backup recovery.
The nice part is, if you try
to put it in these storage
options, you have an option to
run ad-hoc queries if you want,
because you have that
environment ready.
You don't have to
replicate a lot.
So that might be another
thing to think about.
OK, if you look at--
so the Google
Cloud Connector is,
in fact, one of the cornerstones
of the whole implementation
if you're going to
go Google Cloud.
Why?
Because first of all, you
have to get your data in.
And I'm going to show
you a couple of options
that you have to get your
data into the system.
But first of all,
GSF, GCS, and HDFS
are implementations
that are interoperable.
You can quite easily implement
the access to your files,
actually, by changing the
protocols to, for example,
GS://.
There is a difference though.
HDFS has a different semantics.
And I mentioned, a moment
ago, with semantics,
I mean to say that we
have something called--
in HDFS, we have something
called directories.
Cloud Storage doesn't
have that context.
The nice part is that
the world of Hadoop
is starting to understand that
whole concept of not having
directories.
Because if you look at it
from a different angle,
it might not make sense anymore.
Because we're doing unstructured
data all over the place.
There is a pro
and a con on that,
of course, because the fact
that we don't have directories
and other things that
are different than HDFS
has to do with the fact that we
want to have high availability.
So it's up to you.
There are ways to
still do it anyhow.
But for example, if you have
files on which data is added--
so they are appended.
They append data to it--
then you might have to
look into the native HDFS
implementation on Google Cloud
Storage-- of Google Cloud.
So in the end, there
are pros and cons.
But the most important
part is that you do
realize that you have options.
You have options to
move forward also.
So getting data in your system
can be done in two ways.
You have the push-based version
versus the pull-based version.
What does it mean?
So there's tooling on
the command line which
you can, say, distribute a
copy, and all my files are
pumped into the Cloud Storage.
That's just a command
line tool that you can do.
Then you use your internet
gateway, and that's it.
That's the easiest
way to go forward.
But you can, of course, imagine
that a customer would say,
well, no, that's too leaky,
although it's over HTTPS,
et cetera, I still want to
have-- with my firewall rules,
and with my routing information,
I want to have access--
sorry, I want to provide my
data to the cloud environment.
So for that, Google provides
Google Cloud VPN gateway,
which allows you to create
a private subnetwork
within the Google Cloud
platform which fits your network
needs for your firewall
and actually creates
a bridge between the
cloud environment
and your environment.
The most interesting part
is that you can query
from both environments now.
You can start querying
from the cloud environment,
because it's like a bridge.
You can query on the
on-premise situation,
depending on the firewall rules.
But also, from the
other side, you just
can query the data that's
stored in Google Cloud.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ROKESH JANKIE: Does makes sense.
So there are a couple of
options that you have here.
So another result of
doing all these migrations
and thinking forward--
and of course, if you have
pain, you try to fix it--
is to think about some bigger
architectural concepts.
So one of the most important
things in Cloud Dataproc is--
the way we think about it is,
if people start a cluster now,
the first question that
you get is, how much
data are they going to store.
So people start ramping
up hard disks and saying,
OK, I want so much petabytes of
data for a hard disk available.
We, in Google Cloud, think
differently on this context.
Because this concept
in Hadoop, which
is called bin packing
and data locality,
both things are
very important when
you start to implement your
Hadoop cluster on premise
or in a hosted environment.
But the most important part is
that if you start doing that,
you're adding complexity
to your cluster.
Because managing that part is--
what I mentioned
in the beginning
is it's going to create
[INAUDIBLE] in your operations.
And it's going to
make it more complex.
The cool part of
this whole story
is that the Hadoop cluster,
with separate storage,
supports bin packing
out of the box.
And data locality is
something you don't even
have to think about.
Because the Google
Cloud can make sure
that the data is
close to you depending
on how you start your cluster.
So if you do this,
that's another note
that is very important.
So if you define
compute and storage--
if you define those two--
you can start thinking in
different concepts now.
Because if I say--
if, initially, you said that the
computation power of-- sorry,
the computation hours--
were like 10,000--
10,000 hours to, for example,
do a data analysis part--
you now can say, OK, so that was
one hour, 10,000 CPUs, vCPUs.
And now you can say, OK,
give me 20,000 vCPUs.
And in a half an hour, I
have my data processed.
Or give me 100 vCPUs and
100 hours of processing.
That's up to you.
The good part is you have
the freedom in the end.
Because in the end, the total
cost of all those three options
are the same.
If you do 10,000 one
hour, 20,000 half an hour,
or for 100 in 100 hours, the
cost for the Google Cloud
platform is the same.
So now you see that
you can process
the same kind of information
in less time, because you
can burst and allocate
quite some CPUs.
Because you've make the
distinction between storage
and compute.
Another very nice thing-- and I
noticed it in my demo also when
I was preparing this--
is the cost saving
through preemptible VMs.
What are preemptible VMs?
So who of you are
in the dev ops area,
who are building and
creating VMs, maybe, in your
build process?
So preemptible VMs
are exactly meant
for those kinds of situations.
Because what happens is that,
if you build, you run a test,
and then you kill
the VM again, right?
Normally, you would buy a
contract, or sign for a year,
or have an hourly
billing situation,
and even if you use
it, like, 10 minutes.
So a preemptible VM-- so first
of all, minute-based billing.
And another thing
is they are like 20%
of the price of an original VM.
Because we know you're
going to throw it away.
And that's another thing.
If you don't throw
it away, Google
has the right to
reclaim that capacity.
Because if you're not
doing anything with it,
and it's not meant to live
long in your cluster--
and that's actually the nicest
part of Google Cloud Dataproc.
As fast as you
bring it up-- like,
in one and a half minutes--
even faster, you
can break it down.
And that's actually quite cool.
And it saves quite some money.
Because each of the VMs
that we have is, like,
20% of the cost
of an original VM.
And I calculated, the simple
VM is, like, $1 a day.
And it's $0.20-- sorry, it's
$1 per hour, more or less.
And it'll become,
like, $0.20 per hour.
Another thing that the
Google Cloud supports
is that if you have a workload
like on that side, which
is full, you might
notice that you are not
using the full capacity.
And that's the thing, right?
We have a shortage of DRAM,
and hardware, and stuff.
And it's going to
cost you if you
start using quite large
clusters which are incidentally
using it.
That's going to cost
you quite some money.
So what you can do
here, and that's
actually a quite nice
feature of Google Cloud--
we have rightsizing in place.
So you can even say, I want
three CPUs, instead of four,
with a strange
amount of gigabytes.
The craziest configuration
is possible in this context.
Another thing is that if
you use the Google Cloud,
you will also notice that we
are going to recommend you
at some moment, because
we noticed that you're not
using the full capacity.
And we like to
advise you on that.
Because you're going to get
a cost-saving marker also,
in your console.
And another thing is,
don't make just one
cluster to do everything.
Think about your clusters.
Because you separate the
compute power from storage,
you can now think about doing
the ETL stuff in a different
cluster than your
machine learning stuff,
than your Hive analytics,
than-- what is it--
business reporting--
also quite big.
But as you guys
probably already know,
machine learning consumes
quite some power, especially
compute power.
And for that, you can
create a different workload.
You can create a
different cluster
with a different configuration,
with lots of CPUs, GPUs, VPUs,
maybe, and low on memory maybe.
So this is also, note,
something to think about when
you start moving forward.
And of course, we can kill
the surface quite fast.
So if you use it, then you say
OK, drop it and throw it away.
But there's something called
a semi-long-lived cluster.
And actually, that's
very interesting.
So consider this
following situation--
I have to keep
track of the time.
Consider the
following situation,
that you have your cluster--
it's production, it's
version 1, whatever--
but Hadoop has a new release
coming up which is 10x faster,
or maybe has-- the
whole complexity
that you're handling
in pipelines,
reduces it to one command.
The nice part is you can start
doing load balancing between--
and canary testing-- for those
who know that term, that's
about trying the
latest, greatest,
but not breaking your
whole production.
So you can create clusters
with the newest version
and make it part of
your production process.
You can even start
testing, will it
work for me, will
it help me, will
it create value in the end.
So we have many--
so you can start creating
clusters in a group.
And that acts as one.
And just test it with your
data, see if it works.
And at some moment,
you could say,
I'm upgrading all my
clusters to that version.
That's actually, like,
four lines or four clicks.
That's really impressive
if you see that in action.
So we want to see things in
action, so let's go for it.
I have some comments here.
So first of all, do mention
if it's not readable.
That is readable, right?
So instead of typing
all the commands,
I have, here, a cheat sheet.
And let me make it a bit longer.
So first of all, what you see
here is that I'm creating an--
it's resetting?
I'm doing a gcloud
dataproc cluster
create rokesh-demo-1 with
number of workers of five.
I added some properties.
We'll see what it actually is.
And I added, also, a
tag with my name on it.
So at this moment, it's
creating a cluster for me.
So in the Google
Cloud console, you
can see that it's already
starting creating a console--
sorry, a cluster-- for
me with five workers.
It's busy doing that.
But while it's
creating my cluster,
I can also say, create
another cluster.
So I'll say rokesh-demo-2.
It's in Europe west, yeah.
And I create another cluster--
bang.
So now a second cluster
is being created.
I also can say-- as
mentioned in the beginning,
I can also dive into
creating another cluster.
Let's call it rokesh-demo-3.
And now I want to use the
latest, greatest of Hadoop.
So we have a couple
of image versions.
And this is a preview
version of Hadoop 2.8.
So you can already start it.
And I said create--
bang.
Now we see that
three clusters are
being created at this moment.
And hopefully, within
a couple of seconds,
you'll see an output
in this context.
That's it.
I'm not sure if it's visible,
but here, you can see it.
In 1 minute 39 seconds,
it created a cluster
in US central.
So the latency is, I think,
part of why it's not been 130.
So now we have a cluster.
And in the meanwhile,
the other clusters
will be coming live also.
So what I can do, the next step,
is show you a native console.
So the people who are
familiar with Hadoop
probably know this
interface also.
So what I have to do now is
create a tunnel to my cluster.
So I'm creating a tunnel.
That's it.
I'm starting Chrome--
let's see about this--
I'm starting Chrome
with specifics
for using the proxy that
is required for doing
this kind of connection.
And if I go to
http://rokesh-demo-1 m--
the master--
on 8080 cluster, I
should be able to--
yes, there I am.
So this is the console
that most of the people who
work with Hadoop know.
It's exactly the same
kind of software.
We're not adding anything to it.
It's just, we're managing.
We make sure that
you can use it.
So this is a Hadoop cluster.
And you can see, in
this one, that this
is the 2.73 release, right?
So Chrome is giving me errors.
Clear.
Then the next step is, OK, say
I want to do native Hadoop.
So that's the thing
I was used to.
So what I do now is I am
going to do a local SSH.
So I'm doing an SSH to the
command line of my cluster
itself.
In a minute, I'm there.
Yep.
So now I'm in the US
central cluster environment.
I can say hadoop char--
and then, where is the line--
user lib.
Let's see-- hadoop map reduce--
let's see-- are you guys
familiar with TeraGen?
Ever heard of it, TeraGen?
OK, just wondering.
TeraGen is like a [INAUDIBLE].
It's a reference set of
data that you can sort.
And it's quite interesting to
do some measurements on it--
map reduce examples.jar teragen,
say I want to have this.
And I'm going to create
it in my Next Amsterd--
Amsterdam teragen temp1.
So what it's doing now, it's
actually doing a Hadoop job
on my cluster at this moment.
And it's creating data.
It's creating lots of data.
So I think this is 100 megabyte
of data in this Google Cloud
Storage location.
So another thing that you always
have is Google Cloud Storage.
So if I refresh it here--
so what we're looking at is
this Google Cloud Storage user
interface.
And files are being
created at this moment.
So the other thing
that's happening
on the cluster, and
an interesting part,
is that in the--
was it here?
This one?
If I refresh this
one, I can see that--
it's needing some time here.
OK, it will be
there in a moment.
But then, you can see
the default flow of all
the processes that are running.
This is still native Hadoop.
You're not doing
something special here.
So another way to run jobs--
because the thing is that if I--
this one is finished.
Unfortunately, I can Control-C
it, and then I'm lost, right?
Then I have to
restart the job again.
But what we can
do here, also, is
I can fire up Cloud
Dataproc project--
sorry, a job-- on my cluster.
And this might be
a long statement.
But what it's doing,
it's firing off a job.
Sorry.
It's firing off-- so what we
do is Google Cloud Dataproc job
submit Hadoop, and
then, the same map
reduce example that you
saw a moment ago, only
I didn't provide it parameters.
The reason why I did that
is to see this error log,
because I did it on purpose.
It's not the demo
error, by the way.
Hopefully nothing will
be coming up also.
But what you see
now is that, OK,
I have an error, so
I have to fix it.
So the next step is
to fix this statement.
And what we're going to
do is we're going to say--
sorry, we're going
to say teragen,
like we just did a moment ago.
And then I can say it's on
the Google Cloud Storage Next
Amsterdam bucket, and
create the teragen-temp2.
Oh, did I miss something?
Yep.
So now it's submitting a job,
and that's actually very cool.
Submitting a job in
Google Dataproc is fun.
Because everything
that everybody
does with your system,
you can record it.
It will be recorded actually.
And what I can do now
is, while it's running,
I can go to the Cloud console.
And if I look at my clusters, I
see that jobs are being fired.
So I had two wrong
jobs apparently.
I can see the log.
And one is running
at this moment.
So another thing to do
is-- if I say Control-C,
I'm not losing the job.
Because what I can do is I
can say gcloud dataproc jobs
await, and then I take
the job ID, Control-C it.
And what it will do is
reconnect to the stream that is
being generated by the output.
And in the end, I'm finished.
So that's something
that you can get.
You can start a job, close
your laptop, go home,
and it will still be executing
anyhow in the background.
So another thing that I
would like to show you--
and I still have time?
Yep.
Nice-- is a thing
called a Stackdriver.
So Stackdriver is like our
monitoring tools over Cloud
environments, if you want to.
So what I'm going to do is I'm
going to create a group here,
call it rokesh-demo-live.
And I'm going to add a tag.
And in one of my first
statements that's here,
I usually tag this.
So the tag is actually
quite interesting.
Because now you can combine
several clusters together
and have a dashboard on
all the clusters in one
go, although they're totally
independent, totally not
related maybe, even.
But you can see the complete
performance of your clusters
that you're running.
Persist, add criteria-- bang.
Save group.
Oh, this one can go.
So in Stackdriver, the
very interesting part
is, within a Stackdriver group,
you can create dashboards.
And the dashboard is actually
quite straightforward.
Because you can
say, for example--
let's see-- the inbound traffic.
Where is it?
It's a bit slow.
I don't know why.
GCP-- yep.
So we have the network
inbound, we make a stack area,
and we filter on
group where the group
value is equal to my demo.
And then I say Save.
And what I can do
is, now, on the fly,
add charts on the
cluster itself.
This is something that is very
powerful which allows you to,
indeed, have an overview
of all your classes
running at the same time.
Of course, we have
something similar, also,
in the cluster
environment where,
if you click on a cluster, you
can see the CPU utilization.
These are apparently the jobs
that I'd tried a moment ago.
Network bytes,
capacity, et cetera,
it's everything
that you can see.
But the biggest difference
with Stackdriver
is that you can
see it in one go.
You can make a dashboard out
of it and show it everywhere.
So I think it's time to
do something really beefy.
So what I did,
before this demo, I
created, with TeraGen, 100
gigabytes of sorting data.
And I would like to have my
Hadoop cluster work on it.
So let's go back to this one.
So this is the statement.
It's the same thing.
The only things that
we're doing differently
is, now, we're doing TeraSort.
So that's the sorting algorithm.
It's for benchmarking.
So we can see what the
performance is of that.
And I will do it on
100 gigabytes of data.
So I submit the job.
And what you see now is that
it's 100 gigabytes of data.
It's not very easy to do that.
It's going to cost some time.
So what I'm waiting for now is
to see the percentages go up.
And if we see it in a bit--
so it's going to be, like,
every 20 seconds, it's
going to do 1%, which
is not that fast, right?
And I already
created my cluster.
So what to do now?
So what you can do is--
so while this one is doing, say,
about 20 seconds, more or less.
What we can do now is we
can go back to the cluster,
go into the configuration.
And this is the easiest
thing I've ever seen.
I say Edit, let's say, 40.
I want to have 40 worker nodes.
So what happens now is
the request is submitted.
It's not canceled.
Yesterday I had a
cancellation because I
didn't have enough quota.
But now my cluster is creating
40 VM instances immediately.
In a moment, they are
available and managed.
The calculation that is
happening will start using it.
So it's spanning
from five workers
immediately to 40 workers.
And hopefully, the
result in a bit
is that you will see that this
job will go faster and faster.
I'll leave it open
in the background.
So yeah, another thing that
is very interesting to show
in Stackdriver itself is,
if you look at something
called fork rate and memory.
And this is actually-- oh,
let me stick to memory only--
memory use.
So line chart, filter, group.
Save.
So the interesting part is--
and if I zoom in a bit--
here, you can now see which VM--
sorry, it's invisible.
You can see which VM is
taking lots of memory,
is taking up all the memory.
And what you'll see at a
moment is, if all the clusters
come together and the 40--
sorry, the 40 VMs
are available--
now you see them
all spiking also.
So actually, you can
see where there's
a bottleneck in your framework.
And you can say, OK, it might
be time to add some memory
or accept compute power.
So that's actually
quite impressive also.
Oh yeah, another
thing that I totally
forget, but is very
important-- so I
created a cluster which was in
a different preview version.
So what I can do now,
here, is I can go to 3.
That's my third
cluster that I created.
And if the network is working--
yes, it is.
It's actually quite slow--
I'll end up in
that cluster, which
is apparently also running.
Oh, sorry.
About?
You can imagine that,
yesterday, the demo was fast.
But if it's there--
what I'm showing here
is that I'm actually
using another version
of Hadoop, which
is version 2.8's snapshot, which
is made available by Google
for you.
And we're taking the
latest snapshot each day.
So that allows you to start
doing the canary testing part.
So if all the things are done,
and you say, OK, it's fine.
My job is going faster now.
Instead of just
every 20 seconds,
it's now every two seconds,
or something like that.
You can say, OK, fine,
kill my clusters.
So killing of cluster or
removing a cluster can be done.
And something I would
like, definitely,
to share with your guys is
that if you have a cluster--
or, sorry, if you
say create cluster,
there is always a REST
interface available for that.
Why is this important?
Because people found out that
we need orchestration tools
like Airflow and
Luigi to make sure
that they can interact
with these kind of clusters
and manage it.
So for all the
actions that you've
seen that I've been doing
today, you can find another--
sorry, the REST version of that.
Going forward, deleting a
cluster is like selecting it,
throwing it away--
bang, that's it.
And that's also
everything that I would
like to show in this demo.
I see we have two minutes.
So managing
clusters, what we did
is we showed that you can
go through raw clients
or through the user
interface of Cloud Dataproc,
create clusters,
jobs, and operations.
We have low-level
APIs versus jobs APIs.
All of them, we don't want
to frustrate you, right?
So if you're used to Hadoop
jobs, go ahead, make a date,
start using Hadoop.
But if you want to use a bit
more sophisticated approach
where jobs are not killed
because you closed your laptop
or because there was
a network outage, then
these are the other
ways to go forward too.
Everything is REST-based,
so all the calls
that are made through
the gcloud command
can be done through REST.
Updating, downscaling,
and upscaling
can be done through the Edit
button, also through REST
if you want to.
Logging and monitoring
is part of the platform.
And even if you have multiple
clusters and a big environment,
which is going to happen
anyhow, you can do it.
So putting it all together,
reference architecture
for burst loads is used
in internet gateway.
And then, we're going to
fire off in the cloud.
We use it, and we throw it away.
And a hybrid
approach is possible,
where you use a VPN gateway
to talk, and bring data
back and forth, and do your
job wherever you want to,
especially if the data
is not necessarily
allowed to be in the cloud.
And you can go full-cloud
native, which, in the long run,
will help you with canary
testing, with upgrading.
I would never accept
an argument that says,
you know, it's been
running for two years.
Let's keep it.
Let's not touch it.
In this case, you can start
canary testing immediately
and say, OK, part
of my workload is
going to go to that
new Hadoop cluster.
And we'll see if there's a
performance gain in that.
So if you want to get
started with Cloud Dataproc,
these are the links.
Tutorials are available.
This code sample can
be made available.
So find me if you want to dive
into these kinds of contexts.
And yeah, for documentation,
you can find quite a bit.
I did my first
presentation on Dataproc
one and a half years ago.
This is more or less
the same product
with lots of extra
features on top of it.
And since then-- so
since the launch,
like, one and a half
years ago-- there's
lots of content, also, to
be found on Stack Overflow.
Follow the discussions,
and find us in support.
And for the rest,
I'd like to thank you
for your time and patience.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]